so during the pandemic i'll tell you
what so at first i yes what happens is
you go what's going on yeah right you
and then you
i remember like going a month
right remember the first news you would
go a month
i'm not gonna make it right yeah and
then you would see
uh it'll june yeah back there and then
june
first was easter or easter right easter
right easter you guys
eyes were popping out we're not gonna
make easter
right and now it's
2021. and now
i've already accepted the predicament
that we're in right
and so what i've been doing is i've been
um engaging in
a lot of deep dish pizzas i ordered it i
ordered
i ordered it from um gold belly and i
have i don't know
it's coming tomorrow okay he made me buy
another freezer
and what is this what's so special it's
an online does it do special
so gold belly is um they should sponsor
it's basically
let's do it you can get anything you
want from
any restaurant across the country so for
instance
if like let's say junior's cheesecake in
new york
you can go through gold belly um or
let's say he got a pizza from like a
small mom-and-pop shop from detroit
you can do lobster rolls from maine how
but how did they make this wizardry work
how did
they put it in they put it in um a
refrigerated
right yeah dry eyes dry eyes so you
gotta wash your fingers because it's not
realized
it's not real it's not real what dry ice
dry eyes
it's not realized is that real ice no
what is it it's a chemical
it's a chemical it's a it is it's it's a
chemical mm-hmm
it'll burn you that's amazing
pizza done now yeah we from different
very some pizza places i don't like
but i experiment we don't eat the same
things i get people clearly i get pies
from south carolina
wow chicken pop pop you get like skyline
chili
sent to you probably cincinnati yeah so
the app is called gold belly
he got he got pork tenderloin sandwiches
from indiana
the frock yeah so i've been
experimenting with those foods that's
exciting so you've been eating your way
through your feelings
about this whole thing he also started
yoga
that's amazing started yoga good for you
i think great a little bit of peloton
that you got one yeah now do you have
the tread
the treadmill or the bike yeah and you
do the programs with
no i like scenic rides see i don't like
i don't need
i don't need no [ __ ] i don't need no
[ __ ] buff
you know me why dude yeah or something
yeah yeah
ronda rousey looking lady you're gonna
be telling
cause the voice in my head is punitive
enough
[Laughter]
come on do it yeah i know i'm fat yeah
yeah i'm [ __ ] here yeah yeah yeah
it's in your mind it goes out of my i'm
dying i want to yell back
you know they can't respond to you well
it's so familiar to me that kind of
abuse yeah
so it just feels like my body goes into
autopilot when i hear someone screaming
where i'm like oh i know this i've done
that my whole life so yeah i respond
immediately i'm like
burpees burpees 150 that's fine
i'm bleeding out of my nose that's fine
like i just i just do
i don't like it and then another thing
i've been doing is um
and i've been better at this and this is
you know more of a serious tone
okay i don't want to get too deep into
it but it
it it's interesting to see that the
pandemic has been
politicized yeah right and in the
beginning of the quarantine
i um became very emotional about it yeah
right about people's point of view about
it how
their behavior right you know i
obviously i'm a [ __ ] liberal
and i believe science right you're right
as weirdos my weirdo
my bad you know people that have
education and stuff that i don't have
like experts and stuff
telling you what to do right so i'm one
of those you know and then you have
the other patriotic america you know i'm
an american free will
you mean i do what i want to do and i
and in the beginning
i was just kind of resistant to that but
then i realized you know what
people and i've grown here spiritually
people walk in their own shoes i don't
know what their life experience is like
i don't know why they have their point
of view
and it's not my business to try to
understand where they're coming from
right yeah and so i'm been struggling
you know with that but i think i'm a
little bit more empathetic toward
the other side to the people that you're
saying who don't want to wear a mask and
they think it's
it's ridiculous to me but yeah and look
i think people are triggered up by all
this stuff it's not nothing to do with
wearing a mask it's being told what to
do and i think that's maybe how some
people interpret it like what it is
don't tell me what to do mom
dad like they're mad at whoever [ __ ]
with them in the past yeah i don't know
i'm not a psychiatrist but
yeah i think you are i don't care you're
my
phd yeah yeah good nonsense hey guys